here to help you avoid the lefty
booby-traps at the box office our very
own figgy pudding Josh sharp and Aaron
Jackson thank you so much Jordan and
Merry Christmas Merry Christmas - yeah
Chuck it's our segment now as everyone
knows Hollywood spends the entire year
crapping out globalist liberal
propaganda trash and like the Kardashian
children they've saved the worst for
last
Kylie you had such promise so we're here
to tell you which movies to avoid this
Christmas with a special edition of our
signature segment going at the movies
[Music]
[Applause]
first up Star Wars the last Jedi though
really I'd be happier if this movie was
called Star Wars the last Star Wars
right this is the ninth movie in the
Star Wars Canon and the second movie in
the third trilogy and if you still
understand what I'm saying right now
then I just blocked you on grind yeah I
hate this poster there's nothing
Christmasy about it yeah would it kill
you to CGI a Santa hat on Skywalker or
did you blow your whole effects budget
giving Mark Hamill charisma yeah also
I'm confused which one of these social
justice warriors is the last Jedi if
it's space Katniss over here or the
creepy guy from girls ultimately this is
just more Hollywood female empowerment
drivel I mean that woman is the lead
it's all wrong Star Wars has a formula
Carrie Fisher is the token woman she
always has been and she always will be
we yeah like a year ago Debbie Reynolds
to what I know we should move on though
okay next up is the post which is pretty
much just spotlight without all the labs
yeah oh
Spielberg Streep and Hanks all in one
movie glorifying the Jeff Bezos
Washington Post if I wanted to watch a
liberal circle-jerk I'd sit in the Sun
at the Crunch gym in Williamsburg I was
banned from there for eating nachos out
of a fanny stain and there's nothing
Christmas about a newspaper where are
the Christmas movie
okay how about our next film the shape
of water nope it's an art movie about a
deaf-mute woman who a fish god typical
progressives trying to push the culture
forward and make Americans more
comfortable with bestiality when
conservative America is only just now
warming up to pedophilia and it's still
not Christmas the fish should be an elf
the water should be snow the woman
should be me and it should all be a
museum damn it Hollywood get it together
luckily though there is one place to
find Christmas movies that reflect real
conservative ideals and classic holiday
tropes all you have to do is turn your
TV to lifetime or one of the two
Hallmark networks and let the Christmas
wash all over you like hot cheese on
sauna notches yes the lifetime Hallmark
Christmas movie genre has managed to
dodge the leftist thought machine
sticking instead to simple clear Family
Values namely that a woman has no value
without a family night our current
favorite is with love , Christmas with
love , Christmas is about hot shot at
executive Melanie a worthless single
woman who must find a man by Christmas
or else her vagina will turn to dust we
see her out and about doing Christmas
stuff but it's like what are you
celebrating you're single yeah
luckily though single sad Melanie gets
paired on a work project with Donovan
who looks like the property brothers
straight cousin then I don't know
something something secret santa and
then they all fall in love boiler alert
they always fall in love and if you miss
the unique gem that is with love ,
Christmas worry not the lifetime
hallmark Avril offers a huge range of
totally one-of-a-kind standalone movies
with the exact same plot where a woman
has to find a man before Christmas like
a boyfriend for Christmas a bride for
Christmas a Christmas wedding tail
hitched for the holidays no bride will
you marry me a Royal Christmas round for
Christmas princess for Chris sorry
what's that we're short on time okay
we'll double up hiring me a Christmas
holiday and a show Christmas that 9
license Christmas all I want for
Christmas Hallmark lifetime again these
are all real movies and we see you chuck
you're flying through it the Christmas
magic Christmas miracle Christmas story
and my Christmas prints not to be
confused with a Christmas Prince which
is the Netflix option for all youth
snobs out right so this Christmas skip
the theater and stay at home yeah and to
all the single ladies out there remember
there's only 13 shopping days left until
your vagina turns to dust guys I loved
it I love
[Applause]
we can throw it to commercial on our own
or on thin ice charges thanks for tuning
in opposers now it's commercial time
[Applause]
[Music]